glücklich sind wir möglicherweise alle
auf sehr unterschiedliche weise im
unglück aber werden wir uns sehr ähnlich
dies hat damit zu tun dass wir in jeder
krise in die wir geraten mit den
grundbedingungen der menschlichen
existenz zu hadern beginnen mit der
sinnlosigkeit des lebens mit dem tod und
damit dass wir letztlich selber
verantwortlich sind wie unser licht
ausgeht
dies zumindest behauptet rw ahlen ein
gefeierter besten autor ein
psychotherapeut und ein ehemaliger
professor für psychiatrie aus stanford
und mit ihm diskutiere ich heute darüber
ob wir tatsächlich alle am gleichen
kranken und die wir letztendlich
glücklich werden
vor noch nicht allzu langer zeit hat man
wo die airline an einem filmfestival in
cannes gefragt was er eigentlich schon
tot hält und er hat gesagt ich bin
strikt dagegen sind sie auch dagegen
immer gern ob ich gegen den tod bin so
leid es mir tut aber man kann nicht
gegen den tod sein er ist unvermeidlich
unser aller schicksal
wir versuchen das zu verleugnen
wir möchten glauben wir würden ewig
leben manche erfinden religiöse mythen
nach denen wir in der ewigkeit
weiterleben aber ich glaube dass unser
leben nach einem zeitplan abläuft es
beginnt gegeben es und es endet an einem
gewissen punkt
ich kann also nicht gegen den tod sein
ich mag ihn vielleicht nicht aber darf
kein feind sei sie sagen irgendwo in
einem ihrer bücher das alle menschen
angst haben vor dem tod inklusive sie
und gleichzeitig halten sie die angst
vor dem tod ein stück weit auch für
irrational
warum ich glaube nicht dass diese angst
irrational ist als ich das buch in die
sonne schauen schrieb formulierte ich
den untertitel sehr bewusst wie man den
horror vor dem tod überwindet nicht wie
man die angst vor den toten befindet
denn die angst vor dem tod ist
universell die hat jeder aber für
gewisse menschen ist es ein richtiger
horror der einen großteil ihres lebens
beherrscht sie bis in den schlaf
verfolgt und ihnen albträume bereitet
diese leute kommen zu mir um diesen
horror zu bewältigen
und ich kann den meisten helfen aber die
angst vor dem tod zu überwinden ist
ziemlich schwierig persönlich habe ich
mich fast mein ganzes leben lang mit dem
tod auseinander gesetzt
professionell habe ich damit begonnen
als sich mit patienten arbeitete die
eine tägliche krebsdiagnose hatten
das war vor langer zeit vor 40 jahren da
habe ich viele patienten auf diesem weg
begleitet bei dieser arbeit wurde mir
ganz natürlich mein eigener tod gewusst
was eine intensive auseinandersetzung
mit mir selber voraussetzt ich ging in
die therapie und konfrontierte mich mit
meinen eigenen ängsten und albträumen
sie sagen ja dass die angst vor dem tod
etwas ist das uns alle begleitet und was
viele probleme in unserem leben
verursacht ich habe manchmal den
eindruck eigentlich verdrängen wir den
tod doch primär ja ich denke in vieler
hinsicht verdrängen wir tatsächlich die
angst vor dem tod ich denke die angst
vor dem tod ist wohl die mutter aller
religionen
ich glaube dass alle religionen aus dem
bedürfnis entstanden sind uns ein
gegenmittel gegen unsere todes gedanken
zu verschaffen
die ägyptische kultur zum beispiel baute
sehr stark auf dem jenseits auf und auf
den dingen welche die menschen in die
andere welt mitnehmen
einschließlich ihrer sklaven diese angst
ist universell
alle menschen kennen sie
ist es unzulässig an einen gott zu
glauben um die angst vor dem tod so zu
überwinden
ich denke damit will ich niemandem zu
nahe treten aber ich denke das ist einer
der gründe warum wir gott erfunden haben
als eine möglichkeit diese ängste zu
überwinden oder zu lindern
dank dem glauben im zukünftigen leben
mit gott vereint zu sein und einen
himmel oder ein paradies zu haben indem
wir angenehm leben können und von all
den menschen umgeben sind die wir lieben
diesen mythos gibt es in vielen
religionen
sie machen in ihrer psychotherapie die
sie anbieten sehr oft eine übung mit
ihren patienten indem sie eine linie
zeigen lassen ich habe ihr papier
mitgenommen und einen stift
wenn ich sie bitten dürfte diese minimal
zu zeigen wie sie das machen und was
dann daraus folgt das mache ich manchmal
um den menschen zu helfen in ihrer
existenziellen themen einzutauchen
ich fordere sie auf eine linie auf ein
blatt papier zu zeichnen
sie zeichnen vielleicht so eine linie
dann sage ich das ist der beginn ihres
lebens und das ist das ende
können sie sagen wo sie sich jetzt sehen
manche leute zeichnen sich zb hier ein
eine frau tat das kürzel sie war ist 45
jahre alt
ich fragte sie warum sie sich dort sehe
stellte sich heraus dass sie sich
gefangen fühlt in ihrer ehe und in einen
beruf aus dem sie nach ihrem empfinden
nicht aussteigen konnte diese 30
sekunden dauernde übung ist die
grundlage vieler späterer gespräche die
auf wochen dauern
aber das ist natürlich dann die schöne
situation weil sie dann der frau in der
therapie zeigen können dass die linien
nicht weiter gegend der tod vielleicht
erst hier ist oder aber in vielen
situationen wird ja vermutlich umgekehrt
sein man wäre gerne noch hier
tatsächlich ist man aber wirklich schon
fast hier
richtig aber es zeigt den leuten dass
der tod eines tages auch sie heimsuchen
wird
dafür gibt es einen zeitplan und das
muss uns bewusst sein
in meiner therapie verwende ich eine art
gleichung je mehr um gelebtes leben in
uns drin ist desto größer ist der horror
vor dem tod
anders gesagt je mehr wir bedauern was
wir nicht gelebt haben desto mehr
fürchten wir den tod
eigentlich finde ich das ein bisschen
beängstigend wenn man sich überlegt wie
viele menschen vielleicht tatsächlich
schon relativ alt sind wissen sie werden
nicht mehr unendlich viel lebenszeit
haben und dann sagen sie man stirbt aber
sehr viel besser wenn man glücklich war
mit der sache die man da gemacht hat und
die kunst wird größer vor dem tod wenn
man unglücklich ist mit dem gang der
dinge die er war
was können sie dann in einer therapie
noch anbieten man kann die sache ja
nicht ungeschehen machen wie sie
verlaufen ist
all you can make wie man kann erlebt es
nicht ungeschehen machen aber ich kann
menschen helfen den rest ihrer
lebenszeit anders zu leben
ich arbeitete mit todkranken patienten
die das geschafft haben in einer gruppe
von menschen die am ende ihres lebens
standen eine teilnehmerin zum beispiel
war völlig verzweifelt
eines tages kam sie total verwandelt in
die gruppe sie war schön gekleidet ihre
augen leuchteten und sie sagte sie habe
eine große entdeckung gemacht
ich habe gemerkt dass ich meinen kindern
und enkeln zeigen kann wie man dem tod
begegnet ihm herbert das gab ihrem
restlichen leben eine bedeutung die es
zuvor nicht hatte sie konnte ein modell
für ihre kinder und enkel sein
eine andere patientin drückte eine
ähnliche erfahrung anders aus sie sagte
ich sterbe jung aber ich denke ich kann
für meine freunde eine pionieren des
todes seien
ich kann ihnen einen weg aufzeigen und
eine art mut beweisen indem ich so viel
wie möglich aus meinem restlichen leben
machen so ihr seid ich denke also die
verbleibende lebenszeit ist sehr wichtig
eine andere patientin sagte zu mir
nachdem sie einige zeit in der gruppe an
diesen themen gearbeitet hatte wie
schade dass ich erst jetzt kurz vor
meinem tod gelernt habe zu leben
solche dinge kann ich ins bewusstsein
bringen der letzten zeit sehr populär
geworden ließ den zu publizieren von
menschen die eben kurz vor dem tod
stehen die einem dann schreiben oder
sagen was sie eigentlich bereuen ihre im
leben und was eigentlich wesentlich
gewesen wäre und die süßen werden
herumgereicht es gibt auch einen
wunderschönen text von jorge luis borges
dem argentinischen schriftsteller der
mit 85 jahren geschrieben hat wenn er
sein leben noch einmal leben könnte wäre
mir mit kindern spielen er würde den
ganzen tag barfußgehen er würde mir in
flüssen badener für die berge besteigen
sonnenuntergänge ansehen
wir kennen alle diese bilder aber ich
frage mich immer was hat das für mich
für menschen in meinem alter eigentlich
für eine bedeutung denn wenn wir alle so
leben würden wie diese menschen kurz vor
dem todes empfehlen würden dann wäre das
leben ja wahrscheinlich unendlich
langweilig wenn man kann nicht noch 40
jahre oder 50 jahre sonnenuntergänge
betrachten
nein aber sie können ihr leben anders
lieben wenn wir beide so ein gespräch
hätten und ich sie fragen würde was sie
an ihrem bisherigen leben bereuen
würden sie wohl auf einige dinge stoßen
wenn sie solche dinge gefunden haben
würde ich ihnen eine weitere
therapeutische frage stellen nehmen wir
an dass wir uns in einem oder zwei
jahren wieder treffen können sie mir
sagen was für weitere dinge sie in
dieser zeit anhäufen werden die sie
bereuen ihre antwort frage ich sie dann
in diesem therapiegespräch was können
sie tun um in den nächsten beiden jahren
so zu leben dass sie nichts bereuen
anders gesagt leben sie das leben das
sie leben möchten und häufen sie keine
dinge an dies bereuen werden
ich kann sagen dass ich das selber getan
habe
ich habe in stent rollt unterrichtet ich
arbeitete dort einen großen teil meines
lebens als professor aber vor etwa 15
jahren beschloss ich mich vorzeitig
pensionieren zu lassen denn es geschah
dinge in meinem bereich die mir nicht
sondern ich die vielen eine psychiatrie
studenten zeigten weniger interesse an
der art von psychotherapie die
praktizieren
sie interessiert sich mehr für
psychopharmaka für neue medikamente und
die veränderungen in der gehirnforschung
als für meinen therapieansatz
da beschloss ich mein wissen über meine
bücher der ganzen welt zu vermitteln
bringt mich von meinen verpflichtungen
in sternfeld zu befreien seit er
verbringe ich meine tage so wie ich will
am vormittag schreibe ich am nachmittag
habe ich zwei oder drei patienten und
wenn ich an die letzten jahre
zurückdenke realisiere ich dass ich noch
nie so zufrieden war
ich bereue nichts von dem was ich tue
und so möchte ich leben
und wenn sie diese übung schon mit 40
gemacht hätten und mit 40 schon
entschieden hätten nicht mehr aus
professor zu arbeiten dann wären sie nie
so erfolgreich geworden also was ich
damit sagen will ist uns man nicht
zuweilen schon relativ weit
fortgeschritten sein im leben dass man
es sich leisten kann
diese gedanken zu haben und entsprechend
dann in die tat umzusetzen
sie meinen wenn ich damals zufrieden
gewesen wäre mit meinem leben
dann hätte ich ja auch nichts bereuen
wenn sie mit 40 schon gedacht hätten sie
würden gerne etwas ganz anderes machen
mehr bergsteigen oder nebenflüssen baden
und sie wären ausgestiegen dann hätten
wir alle diese schöne bücher nicht
stimmt aber es entspricht meiner inneren
welt dass ich gerne schreibe ich wollte
schon als kind schalten
als teenager lasse ich gerne fiktive
geschichten
ich lebte in einem gefährlichen viertel
in dem der sicherste ort die bibliothek
war
deshalb wollten meine eltern dass ich
viel zeit dort verbrachte damals
verschlang ich bücher und war schon in
frühen jahren überzeugt das beste was
man im leben tun kann ist einen guten
roman zu schreiben
genau das hat sich all die jahre
angebaut
ich bin es langsam angegangen habe ich
habe sogar in meine psychologischen
sachbücher zum beispiel in einem
fachbuch über gruppentherapie ein paar
kleine geschichten hinein geschnitten
sie sind nicht länger als ein abschnitt
oder 2 aber ich weiß dass das buch
deswegen so erfolgreich war
meine studenten sagten zu mir es liest
sich ein wenig für einen roman
manche fanden ich setze mich mit all der
trockenen theorie auseinander weil auf
den nächsten seiten vielleicht eine
interessante kleine geschichte folgt das
waren meine ersten schritte in der welt
des geschichte
aber es ist eine leidenschaft die mich
mein ganzes leben begleitet hat und
jetzt endlich mache ich das was ich
schon immer tun wollte
sie haben eine sehr sehr große zeit
dieser lebensspanne die sie jetzt
überblicken mit ihrer frau marilyn
zusammen verbracht
schauen wir uns doch dazu einen
ausschnitt aus dem film porträt von
sabine gisiger ein kind hofft porträt
über sie und das läuft gegenwärtig in
den schweizer kinos
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
sie müssen lachen wenn sie diese bilder
sehen das macht sie offenbar glücklich
ihre frau zu sehen
es macht mich sehr glücklich ich kenne
sie seit ihrem 14 lebensjahre in der
schule war ich ein halbes jahr hinterher
aber sie war die beste ihres jahrgangs
die klassenbeste ich war zugegen als sie
ihre rede hielt und bewunderte sie
ungemein
wir hatten eine andere beziehung als
viele teenager
wir sprachen über die bücher die wir
lassen mit ihr konnte ich meine ideen
austauschen
wir lasen beide sehr gerne diese art von
intellektueller freundschaft verband uns
immer während meiner ganzen ausbildung
zum psychiater studierte sie auch und
doktorierte in französischer und
deutscher literatur
ich begann mich für philosophie zu
interessieren und gleichzeitig schrieb
sie ihre dissertation über kafka und
kamin
wie sie sehen hatten wir viele
gemeinsame interessen in vieler hinsicht
habe ich wegen ihr begonnen mich für
diese philosophen und schriftsteller zu
interessieren
ein bisschen klingt das ja fast schon so
was wären sie für einander bestimmt
gewesen gibt es glaube nicht daran aber
es fühlt sich so an als ich sie
kennenlernte wettete ich dann auch mit
meinem jüngeren cousin und 30 dollar
dass ich sie heiraten würde
bis 15 da war ich 15 jahre alt
er bezahlte mir die 30 dollar an der
hochzeit er erinnerte sich an unsere
wette ich war mir sehr sicher
wir hatten eine äußerst tiefe verbindung
die bis heute anhält
sie stammen ja selber aus sehr einfachen
verhältnissen ihre eltern sind in den
1920 er jahren aus russland eingewandert
in die usa sie hat in ein
lebensmittelgeschäft in washington und
relativ wenig zeit für sie schreiben sie
im rückblick so dass sie wie sie schon
gesagt haben viel zeit eben in den
bibliotheken verbracht haben und sie
schreiben auch in einem ihrer bücher das
sie als junger mann selber
schlafstörungen hatten sie litten unter
ängsten woran legten sie was war
schwierig für sie in ihrer kindheit
das ist eine gute frage
es gab so viele dinge einerseits lebt
sich in einem gefährlichen viertel
andererseits hatten meine eltern und
sehr wenig zeit für mich sie arbeiteten
im laden von morgens früh bis 10 uhr
nachts außer sonntags sich nie mit ihnen
sondern immer mit meiner sieben jahre
älteren schwester meine mutter hat uns
gekauft und das essen auf dem herd
gelassen wir haben es aufgewärmt und
zusammen gegessen
als meine schwester dann aufs college
ging er sich an ein
dann war da noch die sache dass meine
eltern aus einem russischen ghetto kam
sie waren in die usa eingewandert aber
alle ihre freunde stammten aus ihrem
herkunfts dorf aus dem gleichen stätte
das war ihre ganze welt ich wollte aber
nicht in dieser welt sein und sie
wollten das auch nicht sie wünschten
dass ich in die amerikanische kultur
eintauchte aber ich wusste nicht wie und
auch das macht mir angst
ich bin daran meine memoiren zu
schreiben
vielleicht bin ich im richtigen alter
dafür erst kürzlich habe ich einen
wachtraum aufgeschrieben den ich auf
träumte er geht folgendermaßen ich
trainiere jeden tag auf meinem fahrrad
und wenn ich zu treten beginne erfasst
mich dieser traum
ein mann betritt den kleinen
lebensmittelladen meines vaters er ist
elegant gekleidet mit hemd und krawatte
und er sagt zu meinem vater ich muss mit
ihnen sprechen
mein vater geht mit ihm in den hinteren
teil des ladens und ruft meine mutter
nach unten damit sie den laden übernimmt
wir wohnten im stock darüber der mann
sagte meinem vater ihr sohn ist sehr
klug
ich denke er sollte eine bessere schule
besuchen eine privatschule
er bekommt vielleicht stipendien damit
er diese schule besuchen kann
mein vater ist verwirrt er versteht
nicht
und damit endet er wacht raum
doch er kommt immer wieder und er hat
eine große macht ja im rückblick weiß
ich dass ich mir einen mentor wünschte
der mich an der hand genommen und
geführt hatte ich musste mich selber
erfinden
ich hatte nie einen mentor erst viel
später im leben der traum war so etwas
wie die bestätigung du musst dich selber
erfinden
du bist mein eigener vater aber du musst
einen preis dafür bezahlen
der preis ist das gefühl kein fundament
zu haben wenn ich einen patienten
betreuen etwas ähnlichem leidet sage ich
du bist wie eine lilie in einem sumpf
die keine wurzeln hat so fühlte ich mich
sehr oft das geht nicht nur mir sondern
fielen aus der ersten generation von
emigranten die eltern haben ihre heimat
verlassen und müssen sich in einem neuen
land
recht finden natürlich eine sehr
spezielle geschichte auch sehr
berührende geschichte wenn ihr davon ein
stück weiter zurück treten dann fällt
mir ein dass es die us amerikanische
autorin amy chua war die ist hierzulande
auch sogenannte teilnahmen berühmt
geworden
die hat in ihrem neuesten buch der tritt
package gesagt im grunde genommen sind
kinder die ängste haben in der kindheit
die ein stück weit auch unter druck
stehen angst haben nicht erfolgreich zu
sein
schlussendlich die erfolgreichen
erwachsenen und sie sind ja eigentlich
ein sehr sehr gutes beispiel dafür
also könnte man umgekehrt nicht sagen
was vielleicht gerade die angst sie so
erfolgreich gemacht hat
ich denke dass stimmen zu einem gewissen
grad
aber ich zahlte einen hohen preis dafür
häufig wenn ich denke wie viele ängste
ich in meinem leben durchgemacht habe
war der preis sehr hoch
ich wünschte ich hätte damals eine
therapie machen können und der therapeut
hat die mir geholfen
ich schreibe gerade in einem imaginären
gespräch das ich vielleicht mit meinem
therapeuten gehabt hätte mit einem
therapeuten wie ich es ist also ein
gespräch zwischen mehr als 13 jährigem
und mir als therapeutin und was daraus
entstanden wäre
es macht mir großen spaß das zu
schreiben
aber der preis den man zahlt ist sehr
hoch es braucht eine art getriebenheit
ich weiß nicht doch etwas war wohl bei
mir ein wenig anders
ich war nicht nur ehrgeizig sondern
hatte eine große liebe für die literatur
und zwar schon sehr früh als ich 15
jahre alt war hatte mein vater einen
herzinfarkt und starb fast daran
diese geschichte habe ich mehrfach und
in mehreren büchern erzählt
als der arzt mitten in der nacht kam und
sich um ihn kümmerte war das für mich
und meine eltern eine unglaubliche
erleichterung
wir hatten schreckliche angst und er
konnte uns beruhigt da fasste einen
entschluss und sagte mir genau das
möchte ich anderen menschen weitergeben
ich bin arzt werden ich hatte also diese
zwei ziele
ich wollte schriftsteller und heiler
werden diese beiden ziele gehören
zusammen und begleiteten mich ein leben
lang
sie mussten ja lange kämpfen bis sie
diesen weg zurücklegen konnten es gab
damals eine 5 prozent beschränken für
juden an amerikanischen universitäten
für ein medizinstudium sie haben dann
einen platz ergattert aber es war
schwierig und waren dann sehr sehr
erfolgreich auf diesem weg aber wenn ich
alle die steine und gucke die man ihnen
in den weg gelegt hat natürlich kann man
davon nicht verallgemeinern aber
trotzdem ist es nicht so dass wir heute
zuteil die kinder oder die jugendlichen
ein bisschen verglichen und zu wenig
fordern
ich bin nicht sicher ob ich diese frage
beantworten kann
ich habe sehr erfolgreiche kinder
gesehen ich habe selber kinder die
erfolg haben ohne solche ängste und
hindernisse ich habe eine tochter der
medizin studiert hat und eine sehr
erfolgreiche ärztin geworden ist und
eine enkelin die auf dem weg dazu ist
ich musste enorme hindernisse überwinden
aber nur bis zu einem gewissen punkt
als ich mein medizinstudium
abgeschlossen hatte ging es viel besser
ich wählte die psychiatrie
die mir sehr gefehlt ich hatte mich
schon vor dem studium für diese richtung
entschieden damit ich etwas näher bei
den ideen der großen psychologischen
schriftsteller dostojewski und tolstoi
war und ich beschloss sich ja dazu
werden
als ich dann zu arbeiten begann und
mitglied der fakultät von stanford wurde
trat ich in eine brandneue abteilung 1
die stanford university hatte gerade
eine neue medizinische fachhochschule
gebaut und war aus san francisco dorthin
gezogen
ich hatte einen sehr fortschrittlichen
schulleiter ich war ihm von meinen
lehrern an john hopkins hospital
empfohlen worden
und er ließ mir freie hand konnte tun
und lassen was ich wollte ich hatte also
eine unglaubliche chance und die
akademische freiheit genau das zu tun
was mir vorschwebt
ich hatte nie einen job an der
universität ich war nie dekan oder
muster administrative aufgaben
übernehmen ich konnte meine forschung
betreiben und meine ideen erfolgen
von dem punkt dann gab es keine
hindernisse mehr für mich da hatte ich
großes glück sprechen wir über ihre
arbeit als psychotherapeut sie sind ja
schon sehr sehr lange ließen business
diesen fast schon 50 jahre als
psychotherapeut tätig und sie erzählen
auch in einem buch das sie selber als
student eine frau die amische klassische
psychoanalyse gemacht haben
sie haben sozusagen auf der couch damit
waren sie aber unglücklich das hat ihnen
nicht gefallen was kritisieren sie an
dieser klassischen psychoanalyse bevor
ich diese frage beantworte möchte ich
etwas sagen zu meiner reaktion auf ihre
bemerkung ich sehe schon seit 50 jahren
psychotherapeut
da ist mir etwas aufgefallen er
beobachte mich ständig und als sie
sagten seit 50 jahren merkte ich dass
mich das gar nicht berührte ich habe
völlig verdrängt wie furchtbar lange 50
jahre sind viele ihrer zuschauer sind
noch nicht mal so alt das zeigt wie wir
existenzielle fragen verdrängen ich bin
nicht 50 ich mache diese arbeit seit 50
jahren
ich bin also extrem alt aber das
verdränge ich wie sich es mir genauer
anschauen
aber zurück zu ihrer frage
damals war die psychoanalyse die
treibende kraft und alle
bildungsinstitute in den usa waren
psychoanalytisch ausgerichtet ich mache
also selber eine psychoanalyse und zwar
bei einer person der einen sehr alten
freude mischen stil pflegte nicht den
ansatz den viele heutige
psychoanalytiker pflegen meine
therapeutin war unsichtbar sie saß am
kopfende der couch auf der ich lag
ich sah sie nicht sie war sehr weit weg
und auch als mensch nicht mit mir in
kontakt ich wusste nichts über sie und
sie interpretierten uhr was ich ihr
erzählte
nichts davon ist mir geblieben zwei oder
dreimal während der drei jahre gleich
bei ihr war gab sie einen persönlichen
kommentar ab über das was ich sagte
und das weiß ich noch sehr genau aber
keine ihrer interpretation aber gegen
ende der analyse dachte ich das ist ein
sehr schlechtes psychotherapie modell
es ist ein wenig hart das zu sagen aber
ich denke durch meine psychoanalyse habe
ich gelernt wie eine psychotherapie
nicht sein darf
ich musste ein besseres modell für ich
absolvierte noch zwei oder drei längere
psychotherapien und alle waren
nützlicher als diese erste was genau
haben sie denn verändert die ihre
therapieform heißt ja die existenzielle
therapie was ist das genau
existenzielle therapie beschreibt nicht
genau was ich tue ich bin ein therapeut
der ein sensorium für existenzielle
themen hat aber ich vertrete keine
schule die sich existenzielle therapie
ich versuche über existenzielle themen
zu schreiben die alle therapeuten kennen
sollten
denn gewisse patienten kommen mit großen
existenziellen problem zu uns sie werden
zum beispiel von todes alpträumen
geplagt oder sie sind an einem
wendepunkt in ihrem leben
sie haben eine midlife crisis und
verdrängen die tatsache dass ihr
altersmäßig den zenit überschritten
haben
vielleicht machen sie gerade eine
sexuelle erfahrung die ihnen etwas
bringt und sie sind darin gefangen
eine änderung in ihrem leben die wir oft
midlife crisis nennen
es gibt so vieles gewisse leute suchen
nach dem sinn des lebens weil sie sich
sehr sinnlos fühlen alle therapeuten
haben klienten mit solchen problemen
doch ich habe auch viele patienten die
sich nicht mit existenziellen fragen
beschäftigen sondern zum beispiel
beziehungsprobleme haben eine
arbeitskrise oder eine krise mit ihren
eltern
ich wollte nie eine therapie schule
gründen ich habe das auf der ersten
seite meines buches über existenzielle
psychotherapie geschrieben
trotzdem nämlich viele einen
existentiellen therapeuten aber so sehe
ich mich nicht
dann lassen wir diese etikette sozusagen
man auf der seite was ist trotzdem so
dass sie sagen jetzt im unterschied zu
sieben uns freut beispielsweise glauben
sie die wesentlichen konflikte sind
nicht einfach diejenigen zwischen
unbewussten und bewussten sondern die
konflikte die wir haben mit diesem grund
existenzen oder grundprobleme der
menschlichen existenz also eben mit der
sinnlosigkeit mit dem tod damit dass wir
verantwortlich sind für unser eigenes
leben das heißt sie machen eigentlich
eine art verschiebung der kühlanlage
nein das stimmt nicht ganz
für freud täglich eine große bewunderung
in stanford habe ich 25 jahre lang ein
kurs über freud gegeben den ich freut
wertschätzung scores denn niemand
befasste sich mehr mit ihm
ich ließ meinen studenten einige seiner
wichtigen frühen werke lesen
vor allem seine bücher über traumdeutung
und infantile sexualität
ich widerspreche freuen nicht was die
unbewussten kräfte anbelangt und die
wichtigkeit die sie zu verstehen
ich vertrete die sogenannte dynamische
therapie und arbeite auch mit dem
unbewussten
ich gehe einfach ganz anders vor als
freud und wenn die nicht die orthodoxe
methode aber wenn man freuds leben
analysiert
und schaut wie er mit seinen patienten
arbeitete sieht man dass er kein
unsichtbare therapeut war er
interessierte sich oft für das leben
seiner patienten viel mehr als seine
studenten
ich bin also nicht so weit von dem
entfernt was freud selber tat er hatte
eine patientin die von der hüfte abwärts
gelähmt war
sie hatte eine psychische lähmung und er
heilte sie und er schrieb wie glücklich
er was er an einen tanz anlass gehen und
seine patientin tanzen sah er tat was
heutige therapeuten nicht tun
er ließ sich auf ihr leben ein aber ich
tue das viel umfassender als freude
start
ich versuche meinen patienten näher zu
sein mich ihnen zu zeigen und als mensch
mit ihnen zu interagieren
gleichzeitig versuche ich mich
abzugrenzen
ich baue keine freundschaft mit ihnen
auf und treffen sie nicht außerhalb der
therapiestunden 22 bewerber bleiben wir
noch kurz bei dieser geschichte dieser
frau die nicht mehr gehen konnte
sie nehmen diesen fall ja auf und
diskutieren ihn ich glaube es ist in
panama hut oder in einem anderen buchten
gerade unsicher aber der punkt bei
dieser geschichte ist ja auch dass sie
sagen diese sozusagen therapeutischen
extras die sigmund freud da macht
nämlich die eltern sehen die patienten
beim tanzen zuzuschauen
das sind eigentlich die wesentlichen
momente gewesen und sigmund freud sagt
im nachhinein natürlich hätte er die
frau geriet mit seiner theorie der
aufarbeitung des unterbewussten mit der
reaktion der sogenannten das war
eigentlich das erfolgsmoment und sie
sagen nein die therapeutischen extras
sind eigentlich das wesentliche sie
haben ein sehr gutes gedächtnis
ich habe vergessen dass ich bei diesem
fall geschrieben hatte ich meinen sie
ich hätte mich zum ersten mal daran
erinnert ich begann meine lehrbuch über
existenzielle therapie mit einer kleinen
geschichte die thematisiert was sie
gerade sagten ich besuchte kollektion
bei der mutter eines freundes an
mission köchin sie bereitete
verschiedene gerichte vor und gab sie
ihre angestellten die sie in den ofen
schob ich schrieb das rezept auf aber
meine gerichte schmecken nie so gut wie
ihre eines tages beobachtete ich genau
was in der küche geschah und sah wie die
köchin die gerichte ihre angestellten
gab und diese verschiedenste gewürze und
andere dinge hinzu gab bevor sie sie in
den ofen schon daraus lernte ich dass
die extra ist die gerichte so
schmackhaft machte so ist es auch in der
therapie
es kommen viele extras endspiel die
nicht unbedingt teil der offiziellen
therapie sind und zwar weil ich mit
meinen patienten als mensch in bzw
weil ich selber bin in der therapie
einer meiner romane die rote couch hat
das zum thema
darin kann man lesen was passiert wenn
der therapeut vertrieben gesagt
beschließen seinem nächsten patienten
alles über sich zu offenbaren
in diesem roman fantasiere ich was
passieren würde wenn man das als
therapeut tut das wichtigste für mich
ist also die art der erziehung die ich
mit dem patienten aufbauen und dazu
gehört ja auch dass sie die patienten
trösten dass sie auch von sich selber
etwas erzählen dass sie die patienten
auch einmal in den arm nehmen denn das
passt
obwohl sie auch sehr klar in panama gut
sagen was nicht drin liegt sind sexuelle
beziehungen zum patienten aber auch
jetzt mal abgesehen von sexuellen
beziehungen ist es nicht eine gewisse
gefahr dass eine abhängigkeit situation
besteht der patient ist hungrig nach
zuwendung er hat vielleicht große ängste
und sie beginnen fast schon
freundschaftlich mit ihm umzugehen ist
nicht eine schwierigkeit es ist ein
freundschaftlicher umgang wie ihn
freunde pflegen sie sind einander nahe
und haben empathie für einander vor der
passion aber es ist nicht mein ziel dass
der patient eine wunderbare liebevolle
beziehung zu ihr
aufbaut mein ziel ist was sich in der
fachsprache lerntransfer nennen würde
transfair wäre das was die patienten mit
mir erleben auf ihre beziehungen mit
anderen menschen wenn sie zu mir eine
enge beziehung haben die ihn wichtig ist
wird das für sie eine innere referenz
sie erleben dass so eine beziehung
möglich ist dann gehen sie und bauen
solche beziehungen mit ihren besten
freunden und hoffentlich mit ihren
liebes partnern auf so haben sie die
chance sich andern zu offenbaren wie sie
es noch nie getan haben
die gruppentherapie basiert auf diese
idee sie ist ein übungsfeld in dem man
lernt wie man freundschaften aufbaut und
herausfindet wie andere über einen
denken es ist wie in der schule wo wir
ein prinzip verallgemeinern und auf
andere dinge in der welt anwenden
ja eigentlich beim thema der liebe und
natürlich interessiert es einem wenn man
sie und ihre frau marilyn anguckt wie
eigentlich so eine lange liebesbeziehung
so lebendig bleibt ist das primäre glück
oder ist das arbeit eine gute frage ist
das arbeits oder glück es ist ein glück
dass ich eine frau wie sie so früh in
meinem leben kennengelernt habe ich habe
die intelligenz von marilyn sehr früh
erkannt
neben unserer liebesbeziehung hatten wir
auch immer eine intensive intellektuelle
beziehung
sie ist immer meine erste leserin sobald
ich etwas geschrieben habe liest sie den
ersten entwurf und ich mache dasselbe
für sie wir haben also viele
gemeinsamkeiten
sie hatte einen ungewöhnlichen werdegang
für unsere generation
sie ging ans college und doktorierte
niemand aus unserem jahrgang machte das
aber das war ihre bestimmung ihre lehrer
realisierten es schon früh
und vermittelten ihr stipendien um mir
diese chance zu geben ich habe das keine
minute in frage gestellt und sie immer
ermutigt ihre karriere weiter zu
verfolgen
dann bekamen wir kinder
sie war noch sehr jung vielleicht zu
jung wir bekamen vier kinder kurz
nacheinander
im film wird das ausführlich
thematisiert
meine tochter sagte zum beispiel in
ihrem leben würden ihre kinder an erster
stelle kommen schauen die uns diesen
ausschnitt doch gleich zusammen an den
haben wir nämlich auch heraus gesucht
weil es wunderbar zeigten ihre tochter
darüber denkt schauen wir uns diesen
ausschnitt zusammen gleich sie haben den
ausschnitt was für ein zufall habe ich
sie vorhin unterbrochen das ist glaube
ich der ausschnitt den 1
bemerkenswert dass sie gerade den
ausstieg welten ding ich erwähnt habe
das ist eine tiefgründige aussage was
sie sagt hat mit ihrer generation und
unserer kultur zu tun
mit anderen worten in ihrer generation
kam die arbeit an erster stelle
sie war so wichtig den frauen mussten
hart für ihre karriere kämpfen und
gewisse hindernisse überwinden
als ich mein medizinstudium absolvierte
hatten wir nur eine frau in unserer
klasse von 100 studenten als meine
tochter medizin studierte waren fast 50
prozent frauen in ihrem jahrgang
die frauen haben sich verändert und für
sie war es sehr wichtig ihre karriere zu
verfolgen
als nächstes kam ihre kinder und dann
vielleicht ihre ehe
damit deutet sie auch an dass damit
vermutlich ihre ehe sehr belastet war
tatsächlich fällt etwas in unserem leben
und auch im film auf das mich und
marilyn sehr schmerzt alle unsere kinder
ließen sich scheiden als ich den film
sah wollte ich den zuschauern zurufen
zwei kinder haben wieder geheiratet und
leben nun in wunderbaren ehen
[Musik]
aber das ist wirklich passiert und ich
glaube es hat auch kulturelle ursachen
niemand von den gleichaltrigen die
damals wie wir heirateten ließ sich
scheiden
das war nicht üblich ich kannte
niemanden der geschieden war
in der generation meiner kinder werden
50 prozent der ehen geschieden
dafür sind kultur religion
ausschlaggebend und vielleicht gibt es
auch psychologische ursachen die auf
etwas tieferes in meiner familie
zurückgehen
was ist ihre frage
ich finde es sehr bedauerlich und ich
denke alle meine kinder sind traurig
deswegen aber sie denken anders über die
lebenslange ehe die wir haben und die
sie nicht hatten die beiden kinder die
wir heirateten haben nun eine ähnliche
beziehung wie ich und marylin die von
gegenseitiger wertschätzung getragen ist
[Musik]
für sie ist es wichtig einander zu
lieben und sich umeinander zu kümmern
sie wollen dazu beitragen dass der
andere glücklich ist das tun sie nun in
ihrer zweiten ehe wir sagen manchmal
scherzhaft sie hätten in ihrer ersten
ehe üben müssen und haben nun vieles
geändert aber gerade viele psychologen
sagen doch dass die eu oder die lange
liebesbeziehung die eine ganze
lebensspanne überblicken kann wir werden
ja heute so alt die gibt es eigentlich
gar nicht oder es gibt nur ganz wenige
zufälle vielleicht die bei ihnen und
merlin also ist es nicht angebracht dazu
sagen vielleicht ist die lebenslange
liebesbeziehung einfach vorbei das will
ich nicht glauben eine trennung
verursacht immer so viel schmerz
es ist immer schmerzhaft wenn kinder
eine halbe woche mit dem einen
elternteil und die andere woche mit dem
anderen elternteil leben müssen es ist
ungemein schmerzhaften eltern nicht mehr
miteinander reden und diese spannung ihr
leben lang mit sich tragen
ich will das wirklich nicht glauben ich
bin überzeugt dass menschen langfristige
liebesbeziehungen haben kann
ich bin ein großer befürworter von ihm
und ich tue alles um einen patienten bei
ihren eheproblemen zu helfen
klasse nichts unversucht ich dränge sie
eine paartherapie zu machen und alles zu
tun um ihre ehe zu retten
es gibt ja so allgemeinplätze was man
tun kann um eine beziehung lebendig zu
halten
einer ist der zeit miteinander zu
verbringen ein anderer weiterhin eine
sexuelle beziehung auch miteinander zu
haben aber gibt es abgesehen von diesen
gemeinplätzen etwas wenn sie ihre ganze
karriere als sicher da angucken wir
sagen würden das ist wirklich der kern
oder da habe ich ein paar sachen
herausgefunden kleine scharniere an
denen man wirklich schrauben sollte wenn
man in einer beziehung ist und ich auch
behalten möchte
ich denke gegenseitige empathie ist sehr
wichtig ich weiß nicht wie das andere
machen aber wenn ich etwas zu meiner
frau sagen frage ich mich automatisch
wie empfindet sie das kommt für mich
immer zuerst bis zu einem gewissen grad
verhalten wir uns alle so aber für mich
ist es sehr wichtig und ich denke auch
für meine frau ich tue nichts was in
irgendeiner weise verletzen könnte und
ich setze alles daran um ihre interessen
und überzeugungen zu unterstützen
ich respektiere sie sehr wie schon sagte
helfen wir uns gegenseitig bei der
arbeit
ich möchte so viel wie möglich über
ihren arbeitsbereich aus was sie will
und was für sie wichtig ist ist auch
extrem wichtig für mich
ich tue fast alles was ich kann für sie
es gibt eine ausnahme ich gehe nicht
nach frankreich
ich kann kein französisch lernen
anscheinend habe ich da eine
lernschwäche
französisch ist ihr fachgebiet sie ist
französisch professoren ich jedoch
scheine die ungewöhnliche fähigkeit zu
haben jedes französische wort falsch
auszusprechen
sie hat jahrelang versucht eine
französisch beizubringen aber ich habe
aufgegeben
und sie geht nun ohne mich nach
frankreich aber in allen anderen dingen
arbeiten wir eng zusammen sprechen über
die schwierigkeiten in unserer
gesellschaft man sagt heute dass die
depression so etwas wie eine
volkskrankheit geworden ist und das
institut für sozial und präventivmedizin
der universität zürich hat vor einem
jahr ungefähr gesagt rund ein fünftel
der schweizer bevölkerung leidet
eigentlich an gewissen symptomen früher
oder später einer depression sind wir
einfach wehleidig geworden oder was ist
los mit uns kann ich kann nie
verallgemeinern was in unserer
gesellschaft passat
es geht auch darum zu sehen was
geschieht und es zu benennen
aber in vielen kulturen liebe beobachten
signalisieren menschen da sie gestresst
sind
das müssen wir genauer untersuchen um zu
sehen was da schief läuft
ich würde sagen was ich auch im film an
einem gewissen punkt gesagt habe der
schmerz unserer patienten ist universal
ihr leiden wohl alle in den usa gab es
eine richtige bewegung in den 19 60er
und 70er jahren die sogenannte and
counter bewegen
ihr motto war psychotherapie ist zu gut
um nur auf kranke angewendet zu werden
auch gesunde menschen sollten in die
therapie gehen die leute besuchten also
encounter gruppen die weniger dazu
dienten gewisse symptome zu überwinden
sondern ihnen halfen mehr erfüllung zu
finden und zu werden und nähere
beziehungen zu anderen aufbauen zu
können
key accounter bewegungen kam auf und
verschwand wieder in abgeschwächter form
existiert sie heute noch
ich habe ein buch darüber geschrieben
ich sehe es nicht auf ihrem stapel aber
es war ein dickes buch es heißt es ist
als einziges meiner bücher vergriffen
in den counter bewegung ist verschwunden
wie sie aufgetaucht ist aber diese ideen
gibt es noch und leute die in der
business-welt als berater arbeiten
wenden sie an
sie arbeiten zum beispiel mit
führungskräften aus der geschäftswelt
sie helfen ihnen einsicht niebel wesen
zu gewinnen zu erleben wie andere sie
sehen und zu erkennen was sie tun können
um andere weniger zu stressen oder sich
weniger zu ärgern
sie bieten eine art psychotherapie an
eine psychotherapie für gesunde könnte
man es nennen
vorhin gesagt im grunde genommen würde
psychotherapie jedem gut tun weil eben
wir alle irgendwie patienten sind
irgendwo sagen sie sogar oder gehen sie
so weit zu sagen im grunde genommen ist
der unterschied zwischen einer klinisch
kranken person und einer gesunden person
nicht qualitativ
ein quantitativ wir leiten neben alle am
gleichen nur die eigentums mehr als die
anderen bis es an gewissen schwellenwert
überschreitet lässt sich das wirklich so
allgemein sagen und da trifft das nur
auf gewisse problemlagen zu ich möchte
sagen dass es gewisse krankheiten gibt
die ganz eindeutig biologisch oder
genetisch sind und wir lernen von tag zu
tag
damit meine ich psychotische
erkrankungen wie schizophrenie
es gibt immer mehr beweise dafür dass
diese krankheit biologisch ist das
gleiche gilt für bipolare oder manische
krankheiten lassen wir diese größeren
krankheiten weg und sprechen wir über
die mildere formen
ich arbeite mit menschen die daran
kranken und in diesem bereich spreche
ich von leiden die wir alle teilen
wir alle sind gestresst aufgrund
gewisser dinge in unserem leben wie ich
bereits sagte es ist für alle manchmal
schwierig und anderen menschen zusammen
zu sein
wir alle haben mühe mit der tatsache
dass wir sterben müssen wir alle tun uns
mit gewissen dingen im leben schwer
die gesellschaft bietet uns
möglichkeiten an damit umzugehen
die religion ist ein weg sie geht auf
viele arten mit der todesangst um
wie ich schon sagte unter anderem mit
dem glauben an vielen menschen hilft
dass es kommen religiöse menschen zu mir
die sich dadurch sehr unterstützt fühlen
das finde ich wunderbar mir kam es nie
in den sinn das zu hinterfragen oder ihn
in diesem glauben wegzunehmen wenn ich
ihnen nichts besseres anbieten kann
für alle gut eine therapie zu machen
dann erinnert mich das auch daran dass
sie an anderen orten sagen eigentlich
ist das wichtigste im leben sich selber
zu erkennen oder mit sich selber
befreundet zu sein er und das
dranzukommen worum es eigentlich
wirklich geht in unserem leben
man habe ich aber den eindruck
eigentlich ist unsere gesellschaft doch
komplett narzisstisch und wir verbringen
viel zu viel zeit mit uns selber statt
uns auch mal hier und da einfach
umeinander zu kümmern
ich denke man kann beides tun
damit wiederhole ich im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert etwas das
sokrates vor vielen jahren sagte ein
leben über das man nicht nachdenkt ist
nicht lebenswert diese idee wende ich an
es ist wichtig dass du unser leben
lebenswert gestalten es ist wirklich
wichtig uns selber zu verstehen und zu
überprüfen
das heißt aber nicht dass wir
egozentrisch sind es ist nicht das
einzige was wir tun wenn wir uns selbst
besser verstehen können wir auch in
partys ein diakon iwwb mpeg4 locke wenn
sie das leben von sokrates betrachten
und seine interessen studieren sehen sie
dass er alle seine zeit dafür einsetzte
und mit dem tod dafür bezahlt
andere menschen weiter zu bringen er
half ihnen andere zu verstehen und sich
selber besser zu reflektieren und zu
verstehen
verlangt sie nie etwas dafür
er ging jeden tag auf den marktplatz und
machte die menschen mit diesem konzept
vertraut das konzept erst kürzlich ist
das buch plate werde googleplex von
rebecca goldsteiner schienen es ist sehr
populären in usa eine wunderbare moderne
adaption von sokrates und platon
holsteins these ist was wenn platon sein
werk der staat heute geschrieben hätte
und dann alle talkshows gehen und die
fragen der konservativen rechten
moderatoren beantworten müsste es ist
ein amüsantes ab und wirklich
wunderbares buch goldstein erwähnen weil
ich nämlich bei gewissen büchern von
ihnen tatsächlich an die denken musste
weiß ja auch dieses wunderschöne buch
geschrieben habt das leib seele problem
genannt body problem muss auch in dieser
verknüpfung geht von philosophie und und
romanen und wenn wir da vielleicht noch
auf einen roman eingehen wollen
im schopenhauer problem da gibt es ja
auch die schopenhauer chur heißt das
buch die schopenhauer chur
da geht es um einen sexsüchtigen
patienten der sich eigentlich selber
therapiert mit der lektüre von
schopenhauer und da sind ja doch
eigentlich bei der frage was hilft
in dieser selbsterkenntnis eine
psychotherapie oder philosophie ich
würde sagen bald das ist wichtig
informationen über das innere und deren
interpretation als oskar bieg man muss
sie immer kombinieren mit der engen
beziehung zu einem anderen menschen der
einem hilft ein soziales leben zu leben
was ist das problem des protagonisten in
diesem buch ich begann einen roman über
schopenhauer zu schreiben er war ein
außergewöhnlicher denker und hatte viele
großartige ideen aber er war ein sehr
einsamer mensch er war ein misanthrop
ein menschenhasser er pflegte keine
beziehungen mit anderen ähnlich wie
nietzsche wobei dieser doch einige
beziehungen hatte schopenhauer hatte
keine einzige
ich wollte also ein buch über ihn
schreiben und ich dachte mir wäre es
nicht wunderbar wenn ich schopenhauer
eine internationale psychotherapie
verabreichen könnte damit er lernt mit
anderen menschen umzugehen
anders gesagt die beste therapieform für
ihn wäre eine therapiegruppe aber zu
schopenhauers zeiten gab es keine
gruppentherapie
wie soll ich das anstellen also erfand
ich eine romanfigur die schopenhauer
gleicht und auch sein schüler ist das
ist die hauptfigur meines romans ihn
habe ich in einer therapiegruppe
geschickt damit wollte ich zeigen dass
eine gruppentherapie so viel bedeuten
kann dass er einem menschen wie
schopenhauer hilft der roman ist also
ein tagebuch für gruppentherapie
interessant dass alle die großen
philosophen mit denen sich ihre romane
befassen schopenhauer nietzsche espinosa
sind männer die mehr oder weniger ein
bisschen einsam durchs leben gehen
da sind eigentlich wieder beide unserer
ursprungs diskussion macht einsamkeit
oder angst macht unglück geben wie auch
interessant oder erfolgreich richtig das
sind alles einsame männer
ich denke mit einer therapie hätte man
ihnen helfen können bei nietzsche bin
ich mir nicht so sicher
in meinem buch über nietzsche hat er in
der therapiegruppe fasst die rollen
getauscht den user vielleicht er war ein
isolierter mensch vielleicht war er
schrecklich einsam aber wir haben keine
nachweise dafür dass er unter seiner
einsamkeit litt er hat mit vielen
menschen auf der ganzen welt
korrespondiert aber in all diesen fällen
erfand sich eine person die eine art
therapeutische sie war und uns hilft
ihre innere welt zu verstehen noch über
einen anderen philosophen wollte ich
einen roman schreiben
aber das funktioniert einfach nicht
schließlich wurde daraus das sachbuch in
die sonne schauen
ursprünglich sollte das einen roman über
den philosophen epikur werden
in europa wird er oft die piccolos
ausgesprochen
[Musik]
in griechenland sagt man sie wissen nie
wenn ich meine wenn ich den namen anders
betont also über ihn wollte ich einen
roman schreiben und arbeitete mehrere
monate daran herausstellen dass er viel
von seiner lehrtätigkeit darauf
verwendete seinen studenten zu helfen
ihre ängste zu überwinden
das brachte er ihnen bei und ich fand es
wäre wunderbar einen roman über ihn zu
schreiben
meine ursprüngliche idee für das buch
war folgende es würde beginnen mit einem
mann der ein albtraum hat und zwar
träumt er vom tod von seinem sterben
er wacht widmen der nacht schreiend auf
zieht sich angst erfüllt an und sucht
jemanden der ihm helfen kann
jedes kapitel sollte so beginnen
aber immer eine andere hauptfigur haben
und in einem anderen jahrhundert spielen
und der mann im kapitel das 300 jahre
vor christi spielt würde auf ewig uhr
stoßen der ihm mit seiner todesangst
helfen würde
ich schrieb also daran und ich brauchte
monate um alle hintergrundinformationen
zu sammeln
zum beispiel was die griechen zum
frühstück essen und was sie anziehen
ich arbeitete sechs monate langewiesen
kapitel und es funktioniert einfach
nicht
schließlich gab ich es auf und schrieb
ein sachbuch aber das war der vierte
philosoph über den ich einen roman
schreiben wollte vielleicht kommt
irgendwann noch ein fünfter dazu auf
jeden fall sind wir leider schon am ende
unseres gesprächs ich bedanke mich sehr
herzlich dass sie zu mir ins gespräch
gekommen sind
ich danke ihnen dass sie mir so
interessante fragen gestellt haben auch
ihnen danke ich sehr herzlich für das
interesse mehr von der sternstunde
philosophie gibt es am nächsten sonntag
dann spreche ich mit saskia frei von
exit und mit dem palliativmediziner
roland kunz über die zukunft des
sterbens und darüber und wie unser
eigenes ende vielleicht besser nicht mit
dem schicksal überlassen sollten
schauten sie tun denken sie mit
[Musik]